hey i'm deuler and i'm doing the wired
autocomplete interview
[Music]
okay
one what is dewey leaper's real name
it's just duallipa no middle name that's
it it's albanian so that's why it
probably
sounds a bit weird
to everyone
what do a libra song are you
i guess i'd have to be all of them
really in some capacity
what do alipa fans are called
there's no
set name i always just call them my
loves they'd have to decide on their own
i can't it's not my
duty to to name them
what was doiliep's first song the first
song that i put out was called new love
i put that out in
2015. oh my god when i look back on that
video it's so crazy
what is dira lipa's accent honestly i
have no idea british
on most occasions
does do a libra have a grammy i have two
it feels so weird saying it does deuter
speak spanish
i don't but i bloody wish i did i feel
like it's such a sexy language maybe
this should be my
new year's resolution as learned spanish
does do alibaba support liverpool
how do i say this in the best way
possible
i'm like um can you say like honorary
liverpool supporter
only because my dad and brother support
arsenal and i think i'd be getting in a
lot of trouble if i said that i just
support liverpool but i love liverpool
it's always got a special place in my
heart it does do a leap like anime i do
and my favorite anime is ponyo it's the
cutest i'm just obsessed with it does
dewalieba play guitar i don't play
guitar but
i used to play the cello in school and
then i got bullied about it a lot and so
i quit and now i can't play anything
how
did do a libra
get discovered a bit of a long story but
i'll try and like shorten it a little
bit when i was young you know i always
wanted to make music i started making
youtube covers and i started showing
them to my friends in school
and then i use them as like a form of
portfolio to like work with different
producers and get in the studio and i
was like you know i sing and i would
love it if we get in the studio and
write together i made a bunch of demos
and then i basically googled managers in
london and then i got offered like a
publishing deal then i had to find a
lawyer and then the lawyer was trying to
like help me and was like don't sign
this publishing deal whatever you do let
me help you find a manager and he
introduced me to my manager ben and so
that was a really really long story
cut short how is dewalieba pronounced
doer leaper it's quite easy although
growing up i feel like it was really
difficult for lots of teachers and
people to pronounce it
how tall is dewalippa
feet
five foot eight
and
my feet size six uk
how to get dual leaper hair on occasion
a lot of it is bought and glued in
that's quite easy i feel like anyone
could do that but
other than that i struggled to try and
make it look nice bad hair days are kind
of my thing
what
is
homesick
duolifa about it was really i'd spent so
much time away from london and then it
started pouring with rain in los angeles
and it just made me miss london so much
that's what homesick was about was
trying to get back home what are do a
leaper rules
work hard and be nice
what is dewalippa zodiac sign i'm
a leo but i'm also a libra
rising and a cancer moon so i'm
emotional as [ __ ]
but then really tough so don't mess with
me what is duleepa's middle name i don't
have a middle name it's just doer leaper
kind of wish i did
what is electricity
do alipa about it's about love feeling
so electric and and completely sending
these electric messages all up and down
your spine and the feeling that you get
when you're falling in love it's a fun
song this was really a kind of
turning point for me in terms of like
confidence when i when i shot the music
video for electricity
it kind of changed my life it was like
for the first time i was in front of
cameras i was very much in in the zone
and i didn't really care what anybody
was thinking and i just kind of let it
all out and that song will always kind
of represent that for me and i made that
with my friends mark ronson and diplo so
it's always more special when you get to
do stuff with your mates
can do a libra sing i bloody hope so
otherwise i have no idea what i'm doing
it can do a lever drive i can drive i
actually passed my driving test first
time i would always get public transport
but i do really love the freedom of just
getting in your car and going wherever
you want
can do a leave for rap only
at karaoke that's where i like to rap
because i hate singing at karaoke so i
like to rap can dooley for sing high
notes i'm i'm learning i'm learning i
definitely have such a
low voice
so i've always struggled with high notes
but i have been practicing and working
with my vocal coach to be able to just
like
expand my range and learn some new stuff
okay who is dualifa siblings i have two
siblings i have a younger brother and a
younger sister my sister is called rina
and my brother's called jyn and they are
the loves of my life who is dooley but
the singer interesting question to
answer
i am
i guess
dewey for the singer i guess a
songwriter first and foremost and born
and raised in london but via
kosovo which is where my parents are
from and so i always feel like i'm from
two places at once and i i also feel
like that makes me
who i am
who is dual leap assigned to i'm
assigned to warner brothers records
first in the uk and then in the us and
the rest of the world as well and
universal in germany who is dooley's
stylist oh
my amore lorenzo soccer i love him i
love collaborating with him he's been
with me for the longest time we've we've
grown together and it's it's been
amazing love him to pieces
who is dooliepper's mum my mum is an
angel sent from above her name is anessa
and she's my rock and my superhero i
wrote my first ever song when i was like
four years old and it was about her it
was more like a joke of something at
home it was in albanian
and it was all about when i grow up can
i wear your dress when i grow up can i
borrow your shoes when i grow up can i
be as pretty as you and still
my parents make fun of me sometimes and
we still sing it at home to each other
who is deuler's makeup artist today
i have the wonderful samantha who i love
she's amazing and
she makes me feel like a million bucks
was deulipa in a movie no i've never
been in a movie i don't know if i'm
ready yet but i would love to do at some
point i enjoy acting i just my main
focus
is always music
was dua lipa on the voice no i wasn't on
the voice
was dua lipa on x factor i wasn't on x
factor but you know earlier i said i did
like a commercial and then i got offered
like a publishing deal
i did the commercial for the x factor
where i sang for one of their adverts
and then i ended up working with a
producer for it who then offered me the
publishing deal and then i didn't end up
signing that but it was like a series of
events that happened which then led to
me getting to do what i
always dreamt of doing was dewey lipa at
the grammys i have been to the grammys a
couple times it's always
really really exciting i have some
incredible memories
there
all right what have we got oh last one
our dua lipa and bibi rexa related love
bb we're not related we are both
albanian so i guess in that way i feel
like all albanian people call each other
cousins or sisters or whatever like you
see an albanian person on the street and
you're like yeah that's my cousin but no
me and bibi aren't related i'm from
kosovo and i believe bibi's from
macedonia but we speak albanian and
we're very very proud to be albanian
arduino action bronson related again
not related but i do see him as my big
brother
also
got the crazy albanian roots and he also
gives me the best restaurant
recommendations of all time finally our
dewey leaper and taylor swift friends
i love taylor we've met a couple times
she's amazing what an incredible artist
done
thank you so much for watching feel free
to google any questions and maybe i'll
be back and answer yours